uh bonanza creek ranch has had two
people accidentally shot on a movie set
by a prop gun we need help immediately
oh bonanza creek ranch come on
so was it loaded with a real bullet or
one i don't i cannot tell you that okay
is there any serious bleeding
i don't know i ran out of the building
and i still have to go through these
okay are they completely alert
we don't know i can't kill them maybe
hello hi i have a protocol of questions
i need to ask if you can just answer
them the best you can okay are they
completely alert
um yeah they are alert
what part of the body was injured
uh i'm not sure i'm not in there okay
fine is there more than one wound
uh i think there's one on on on two
individuals one wound on two individuals
okay yeah okay i'm now you want
something else online i'll see exactly
what to do next okay
okay